i'm asking parents a tall task to heal
their own inner wounds so that then they
can heal their children how do you
become aware our life is is the mirror
showing us us but we take it personally
we get triggered we project so awareness
is not a given that your partners or
your friends will come to you with like
hey i'm aware i'm an [ __ ] it has
happened never that's why we have
relationships because relationships are
where
you get to see the mirror and especially
parenting unlimited opportunities to see
how fw are so it really depends on the
person's level of truth seeking growth
is so scary for many people because it's
taking accountability
for your own wounds
and we just would rather blame other
people it's so much more satisfying and
easy
this podcast exists because i love
talking to people and i love going deep
the purpose is to plant seeds of
inspiration we enter a space of
vulnerability and relatability and what
you realize is that we are so much more
alike than we are different to quote
ramdas we're all just walking each other
home and this show is just one step i'm
danica patrick and i'm pretty intense
today on the show is dr shafali she's a
clinical psychologist she got her
doctorate from columbia university she
specializes in integrating western
psychology and eastern philosophy
she's a total expert in personal
development patterning childhood and
she's really trying to bring awareness
to
how that affects us in our life she's
written four amazing books three of
which are new york times bestsellers
including her two most famous books the
conscious parent and the awakened family
you know and what i love about dr
shafali is that
if anything if you go look up anything
on her videos on youtube things like
that podcast she doesn't beat around the
bush she would say like i'm not here to
make friends i'm here to help wake
people up and help people sort of step
into their own awareness for themselves
and and be accountable and um
and the big angle is to look at the
childhood and look at that patterning
and look at that how how that affects
you in life
but then become really accountable for
it and so the conversation was all about
that and we talked about triggers
projections attachment styles like the
anxious attachment and the avoidant
secure attachment style and and maybe by
listening you'll be able to identify
with one of them and also maybe start to
identify with a pattern that you're in
where you can identify with one of those
and then you go oh and my uh you know
boyfriend or girlfriend or husband or
wife or partner is this or maybe it's a
work dynamic or maybe it's a family
dynamic and start to identify and then
be able to take steps to take
accountability for your part in that
relationship and then you know we kind
of wrapped up by what transformation
looks like and that you know at the end
of the day sorry guys it's not pretty
but it's all on the path to happiness
which is what we're all looking for in
peace super dense informational show
today and i hope you have tons of
takeaways and you take steps towards
your own awareness and your own
accountability enjoy the show i am so so
fascinated with like human patterning
and
with how especially our childhood plays
into our adulthood like if i want to get
to know somebody real quick i'm just
like tell me about your childhood tell
me about your parents what was your mom
like what was your dad like and i'm like
okay you're the mom and you attract the
dad or whatever and it's just like
it's just such a fascinating topic so
how and the how did you like fall like
come into this
uh
expertise
well
i too am always fascinated by human
patterning and nature and so i've been
studying psychology since my 20s
and also began meditating and
uh the the combination of western
psychology and eastern mindfulness
really became my attention and my focus
and so in my work with people
i would notice these patterns and these
generational cycles that people couldn't
break and began to apply it to parenting
because i became a mother in this
journey and worked with so many parents
and i saw the effects in real time with
adult children who were suffering
because of childhood so i began to just
apply this new way of thinking to my
work and wrote a book
called the conscious parent and then
wrote several other books on parenting
so my main mission is to help parents
become more conscious
of the ways in which those generational
patterns affect themselves and their
children and how to break it so i have
an institute now where i coach people to
help parents i write books on it um you
know i do courses on it all the time i'm
doing a new one in december so i'm
constantly trying to help parents break
these patterns i mean that's exactly my
work so that that the children are not
burdened
by these generational cycles is there a
percentage of of um the population that
has
um like a secure attachment style versus
um a dismissive or an anxious like how
does that break down in society what
you're referring to are attachment
styles and it's been studied uh by this
woman called mary ainsworth and it's
based on john bolby's attachment theory
so this is just the background of people
wondering where whatever styles so
what they did is they they are they like
me understand that connection between
mother and child or earliest caregivers
and children are the most pivotal
connections that we can make and when
that connection is not solid
then it shows up in our styles in our
patterns and the more secure that
attachment those early children years
are the more secure we are when we grow
up so
in my work i only see the ones who come
in in trouble so for me i'll say hundred
percent are our insecure attachment
but i i think there's a truth in that
that
you know the reason we're so effed up is
because
we are insecure within and why are we
insecure we're insecure because
somewhere we believe we're not worthy
where did this where did this belief
system come from
they come from only two places number
one from culture
and especially for us girls and women
culture has told us over and over again
that there is a way to be a perfect
woman
and if you don't follow that way
then you are doomed in a in a way so my
last book i don't know whether you have
it i'd love to send it to you
is this book it's called a radical
awakening it's for women so you should
get that so women especially have been
messed up
with this cultural message that we're
not worthy
and the second place we get this message
from is from our parents
and the reason we get this message from
our parents is because they have this
message that they're not worthy
right so so this is how unworthiness
goes over and beyond oneself so why are
we insecure because we don't believe
we're worthy so
this is what i help parents help their
children with is to to help the parents
enter a sense of worth
and
a strong inner connectivity so that then
they will transmit this radiance to
their children but this requires a lot
of inner work on part of the parent the
parent has to undo their own inner
[ __ ] that they've inherited from
culture they have to undo their own
childhood legacies so i'm asking parents
a tall task
to heal their own inner wounds so that
then they can heal their children
i think one of the hardest things
in my mind is how do you become aware
because seeing yourself seems to be
really one of the biggest hurdles our
life is is the mirror showing us us but
we take it personally we get triggered
we project
where does the awareness come in how do
you actually start to
how can you you know i've watched you
talking about you know narcissism and
like something like that like nobody
goes into a therapist office and go so
i'm a narcissist or whatever their issue
is no you don't walk in with that kind
of an awareness and but i i really do
feel in my heart that most people want
to be good and they want a happy life
and you know if there was a way to
become aware of it
what path would you take people down how
would we get more people to become aware
so awareness is not a given and it's not
a gift that your partners or your
friends will come to you with like hey
i'm aware i'm an [ __ ] it has happened
never right
that's why we have relationships because
relationships are where
you get to see the mirror
and especially parenting are you a mom
i'm not no okay you'll see if you ever
choose to be a mom that you will be
given un
unlimited opportunities to see how f'ed
up you are so you'll be very very
grateful and my sister has three girls
and
she the other night she um she put a
headset on and sent me a picture and she
goes i didn't want to kill my kids
tonight so i put the headset on yeah and
it's like she goes nobody nobody was
nobody nobody left last night
everybody's good but the point is she's
like she becomes really aware of like i
get triggered when they do this and you
know children definitely but also
relationships you know i've been through
my fair share of relationships and
there's always a new level of awareness
and you think you're going into the next
one like healed and happy and well and
bring in your best and then somehow you
find a new level there too yes yes the
relationships
are the place where you get to see the
mirror but you don't have to look right
in the mirror you can look at it you can
look at the issues but you can still
deflect the reflection
so it really depends on the person's
level of truth seeking the person's
level of wanting to create awareness
you know growth is so scary for many
people because it's
taking accountability
for your own wounds
and we just would rather blame other
people it's so much more satisfying and
easy
but eventually there comes a screeching
halt and it's called rock bottom where
you're like oh maybe i'm the common
denominator and that's why with parents
it's i do the work with parents first is
because
you were with your children from the
moment they were born so you gotta look
at you gotta look at yourself and that's
why parenting is so good for humanity in
a way because children bring you to your
knees and you can't blame the
mother-in-law you know you gotta take a
look at yourself when it comes to
parenting so in that aspect
children do us a great favor and allow
us to take accountability but again like
you said it's it's a really tough nut to
to crack because people are so defensive
sometimes i like it's almost when
there's a science to things because it
helps me get past it it's not some an
opinion or something it's just how
things work so what is the operating
system that exists that keeps you in
that
projection mode where you're protecting
yourself
and you can't see yourself like what is
the loop happening what happens when you
just
you just you choose or you don't even
know how to look at yourself like what's
happening that keeps you in this
projection loop yeah great great
question you know it's so funny using
the word loop because i'm doing this
course in in three weeks and i'm talking
about loops and we get into these these
cycles and we can't break out so the
reason we're stuck in this loop is
because when we get triggered right
there's an external trigger
we believe that the trigger
is because of the external
factor
and then we seek to annihilate the
trigger
and we seek to control fix and manage
the trigger
so we try to change the trigger
the trigger doesn't get changed
keeps triggering us and we keep
believing it's the trigger and we keep
trying to change the trigger so if we
get stuck in this mad loop if your
friend comes late for your birthday
party
and you get pissed
you then seek to
control that behavior in your friend in
some way so you yell you scream you
don't talk to her oh your kid says i
hate you mom
you get pissed you seek to control that
behavior you yell scream punish and
don't talk to your kid or whatever your
partner says hey
honey you know i'm not gonna be there
for your uh whatever your presentation
you get triggered you get pissed you
yell and scream we're just stuck in this
little little very tiny circle called a
dysfunctional loop it's so simple and
primitive that when you realize how how
simplistic we are you'll be shocked
right trigger get angry yell at the
trigger control the trigger end the
trigger next trigger same thing and then
we just keep doing the same look yeah
what we are missing is many steps in the
loop
which we are not seeing
number one
i teach this and this is a profound
message but
what i teach is that there is no trigger
and people are like hello what
of course there's a trigger my children
are designed to trigger me they are they
are honed machines
people are desi the whole world is
designed to trigger me what do you mean
there's no trigger
so that in itself is revolutionary right
and what i say is that there's no
trigger on the inside in on the inside
the only trigger on the outside there's
only a trigger on the inside there is no
trigger on the outside so that in itself
pisses people off and they want to fire
me and they don't want to come to
therapy anymore because we've been
raised to believe that the triggers on
the outside
so i'm delegitimizing their whole basis
for their existence their existence was
like no i'm angry i'm blaming that
person i'm resentful i'm holding on
because they believe the triggers on the
outside now are there triggers on the
outside yes
for example if you got raped you can't
say that that was on the inside that was
on the outside or if you've got if you
get caught in a hurricane there's a
trigger on the outside yes when it comes
to our physical safety
physical bondage
there is such a thing as a trigger so if
your husband is beating you up please
yes that is not on the inside that's on
the outside i'm talking about emotional
reactivity all of those triggers are on
the inside life is just so nuanced it's
hard to sift through it when you're
trying to do it for yourself in an
emotional state so like how do you
determine the difference between a
trigger and just someone being
disrespectful or someone not respecting
you or your boundaries or you know uh
you as a person like how how what are
what are some ways that we can where we
can figure out it's a trigger versus
something
else so you first
understand that
the trigger is not just on the outside
it's
it's on the inside when it's emotional
now you turn inward so the next thing in
the loop instead of fixing controlling
and killing the trigger
is look inward you have to do that next
vital step to go okay how much of this
is me i know it's me also
because i'm getting really reactive
right so my friend came late for the
birthday party that is an event
but it's become a trigger because it's
affecting me on the inside otherwise
it's just an event it's neutral
now you look inward and go why does it
bother me so much
that i really don't want to talk to this
person anymore now you investigate now
you deconstruct and then you may come to
the conclusion you know what because
this friend never shows up on time and i
take it as a sign of disrespect
now you can go to the next step what do
i want to do about it now you make a
choice do i want to never speak to this
person again because i think it's it's
atrocious or can i have a conversation
and maybe it's just different styles
of of cultural
you know timeliness
like in india for example where i'm from
it's it's just the culture to not show
up on time it's not disrespectful but
when i came to america
people take it as a sign of disrespect
right so i'm like okay i understand now
i learn i'll negotiate so you have to go
through a process of inquiry and
investigation but why we get stuck in
that loop you talked about is because we
are reactive and we are righteous and we
believe that the trigger is entirely
always external
that mindset has to break if you want to
live a better life and a freer life you
have to
create that pause between trigger right
stimulus and response it's a basic
psychological tool you have to learn
that there are many things happening in
between trigger and response that is
based on our
childhood based on our mindset our
cultural interpretations and if we're
not skilled or don't want to learn how
to be skilled then fine everything will
trigger us no problem be trigger happy
and we are a trigger happy culture
and there is no pause there's no inquiry
and that's why we drink too much and eat
too much because everything is
triggering us look at how many different
things in the world there are with drugs
and drinking and
all kinds of different things even you
can go on the healthy side of things you
can exercise too much you can
you know you can you can go on too many
trips like there's a million ways that
you can avoid the issue what kind of
program could you even go into like
getting into a relationship say you
enter a relationship is there some kind
of like self-auditing that we could do
that would help us enter with more
awareness is there like ground rules
that we should have i mean it's one
thing to have your parents in your
family but it's another thing in a
relationship where you're actively
making a decision to be in it how do you
enter into that with the best of
potential to uh be able to work through
things because the point is is that
relationships i think that in life we're
meant to kind of uncover this stuff
we're meant to grow we're meant to
evolve and relationships give us that
opportunity but they usually end in such
disaster because we just take everything
so personally and we can't deal with it
and we think it's someone else's fault i
don't know i wonder if there's some what
can we do when we enter a relationship
to give us a healthy chance and a
healthy opportunity to be honest and
share and not be offended
yeah i think it's you know
your own inner healing that you've done
on your own path
and then really choosing a person
who you can grow with
but that doesn't mean forever
and posterity but it means that
it's not just blatant dumping and
emotional venting but if there's
opportunity because each person is
working on their own healing so at first
we choose partners just based on
chemical attraction or physical
proximity or you know financial need and
those are the wrong reasons to choose a
partner they can be eventual reasons and
they're good reasons but they're not the
first reasons the first reason to choose
a partner
is a person that you match with in terms
of your spiritual signature in terms of
your emotional healing and you have to
really put emotional health as a top
priority right after you know the
cuteness factor if you want but it's got
to be right up there you know how
emotionally literate are these people
how emotionally articulate how
emotionally cognizant are they you know
in self-literacy self-awareness is
number one
and if that is not placed as number one
in our school curriculums in our
relationship curriculums in our
parenting curriculums we're doomed like
and that's why we are doomed because
self-awareness is nowhere in our
educational curriculum it's nowhere in
the parenting paradigm and it's not
there in the relationship paradigm we go
into these dynamics
of relationships and parenting expecting
the other
to meet our needs
and the other never ever really can ever
fulfill our needs completely or
long-lastingly or consistently
because the other person is deeply
flawed
and so we are really in relationships
with ourselves and others that are
deeply flawed but we go in with such
high expectations that the other will
meet our needs because we're special
and i tell people all the time you're
not special you're unique
you ain't special sweetheart you know
and to the universe you're just the
speck of of a speck of a speck of dust
so
the reason we take it all personally is
because we have expectations these
grandiose fantasies that the other is
meant to complete us the other is meant
to fix us the other is meant to mommy
and daddy us
and the other is a deeply flawed child
looking for you to do the same thing so
now we're competing you know how do but
how do we find that awareness by putting
self-awareness as a top priority in your
own life what does that look like it's
therapy
taking courses
uh meditating
that part of our life has been so denied
by culture because it's not about being
rich it's not about being successful
it's not about getting a trophy or a
prize it's not about being skinny so
that part is a private part it's it's
entering solitude it's sitting and
meditating every day it's writing in a
journal
it's talking to a therapist
is taking a course it's very unglamorous
and unromantic
and it's something you do because you
want to have a deeper connection with
yourself but we've been trained to not
have deep connections with ourselves
we've been trained to have deep
connections with the external world
this is the fundamental sickness of our
world as we've been trained to look
outward to look outside like the
children are more important the husband
is more important the partner is more
important the lover is more important
the what other people think is more
important and we've lost connection with
ourselves but in essence
our relationship with ourselves needs to
be number one now people will say
especially women that that's so selfish
it's not selfish because when you have a
flourishing relationship with yourself
you need other people less and because
you need them less you suck on them less
and because you suck on them less you're
less angry with them so they're actually
better
off when you when you focus on yourself
you know
and uh people don't realize that because
again our eyes are conditioned to look
outward so that's why eastern
mindfulness in my life has been the key
because i can always come back to that
quiet place within myself
and i've developed a very robust
relationship with my own inner voice
so i talk to myself
i listen to myself i first check in with
shefali so that takes off so much burden
of my friends my lovers my partners my
children
like my parents like i'm dealing with my
own self i'm adulting myself i'm
parenting myself and i don't do this all
the time and i don't do it perfectly but
i know that that is the first ally that
is the first step
so you ask what should people do well
they should take that relationship very
seriously
and go to therapy and take courses and
learn about who it is they are and we as
parents need to do that that's why i
teach parents to do that so that we can
cultivate in our children
that autonomy that inner interdependence
what have you done with your daughter
how old is your daughter now you have
one child right yes she's almost 19.
okay this would be fascinating like how
have you
parented her well i've parented her with
a lot of uh bloodshed meaning
i've i've messed up and effed up a lot
so
yeah but through that i learn and i
teach others how to mess up less so i've
at least used her as the muse
scapegoat to help other parents not do
it because i get it when i make a
mistake i'm like [ __ ] and this is why i
did it and now let me teach other people
so i have to have a muse and she's my
muse but i've tried to do what i teach
you know at least half of the time which
is to release her
to her own life
and not take it as
an affront or an applause to my life
it's her own life
and i've constantly given her the baton
to make those decisions you know what
you want to eat check in with your body
you know what you want to wear check in
with your body and if i do have an
opinion
i i say it age appropriately so now
she's 19 you can't really have an
opinion with a 19 year old but if i see
her dressing you know a bit
too risque
instead of saying don't instead of
saying you know don't be a [ __ ] which is
what i want to say i'll say
i'll say instead
i would reconsider
you know how close to showing your
nipples you are you know i'll be i'll
try and tell her in a gentle way because
i want her to make her own decision
you know and i can't what i want to do
is lock her in a box and keep her safe
and protected but i know i can't so as
parents we need to release children to
their own life wisdom to their own body
wisdom to their own self-wisdom
and it's hard with with kids because
they don't have much wisdom so it's like
uh hello you have zero wisdom i see you
being a total idiot [ __ ]
dr shivali how do i release her to a
wisdom when there's no wisdom
yeah but but giving your child your
wisdom is a sure-fire way that they
won't develop their wisdom
pattern
yeah so it's really hard though as i i
feel for parents because there's nobody
more idiotic than a teenager really
they're really really not so smart and
so you have to really have a lot of
patience and trust
to release them to their own wisdom
hoping that they have it but i will tell
you out of just
you know taking myself out of the funny
part of it is that actually we all do
have wisdom
it just takes cultivation
so i know as a parent if i just let her
make her mistakes enough wisdom will
come where does wisdom come from it
comes from error it comes from trial and
practice and for making mistakes so
releasing children to making their own
mistakes is torturous for the parent
because we know
what they should do
but allowing them to experience the the
casualty of their own foolishness is
counterintuitively the way to create
wisdom
you know
yeah i mean that's i i'm not a parent
but i can only imagine how hard it is to
give them enough rope to hang themselves
and you know it's part of the growth you
know my my parents let me move to
england when i was 16 years old and left
high school and lived there on my own
without family and i'm sure that i know
that's what helped me grow and and
become the person that i did because i
had that enough rope and of course i
hung myself a little bit but
i'm curious like what happens from a
young age i feel like they're like i
mean i go up to a kid and i'm like you
know you see this little girl and you
think she looks adorable and you're like
oh my god you're so cute but i'm like no
i'm like wow did you pick your outfit
out today you you know and like starting
to ask questions from a different
perspective and these are just my like
tiny little ways that i approach
children and like you know that was a
great question i'm so glad you asked it
and things that aren't about the
superficial so
anyway the point is is like how what can
what have you done with your daughter to
because you can't
completely avoid the patterning that you
have like you are living your life and
by nature you're
it's
transmitting it to her by proximity
um so what are the tools that you try
and embed in a young child early on
that gives them the
ability to see what's going on have
accountability be able to make decisions
for themselves things like that what
what can you do at the younger ages
yes so the most powerful thing we can do
as parents is take care of our own
expectations
and fulfill our own cup of fulfillment
and happiness so that we are not sucking
our children
and the identity of being a parent
uh and using that identity to fulfill
ourselves which is what many parents do
they use their children as proxy
surrogate
you know buckets to fill their own
well-being
your kid is your your kid that they are
they're only in their own destiny you
are their guide
and that's about it but people equate
parenting as i own you i control you and
you are here to make me feel comfortable
and good about being a parent and that's
the mess up right so becoming aware that
we have to become whole in ourselves is
the best gift you can give your kids
when your kid sees that mom is happy
even when i get a c grade and mom is
happy regardless of whether i never get
an a grade
that is so freeing to the kid
when they see that mom is happy when i
win the baseball trophy or the the
hockey tournament and that's what gives
her happiness
now you subconsciously put pressure on
the kid
that that oh shoot i exist for my mom
parents need to exist for themselves
kids needs need to exist for from for
themselves so i was aware of that as a
mom and really had my own career my own
fulfilling practices
and tried to do both you know be there
for the kid because kids need parents a
lot but also be there for my own
fulfillment so my joy was not based on
the kid there's this adage in parenting
you're only as happy as your least happy
child
and i get that but that's a bunch of
[ __ ] you should be happy no matter
what your kid is unhappy why is why you
unhappy right but that's what we
propagate subconsciously we teach
parents to be enmeshed and dependent on
their children no
teach kids that you're going to be happy
of course it pains you that they're in
pain but pain is a beautiful thing so
the next thing i would say for parents
to do is honor feelings let feelings be
feelings let the kid have their own
feelings we try to control our
children's feelings we suppress our
children's feelings because they make us
uncomfortable
so when you're comfortable with your own
self you allow your kid to be
comfortable and then i would say
especially if you're a mother of a girl
be very careful about your own body
image be careful about how you're
communicating your own life story to
your daughter especially and also to
your son
you know how are you communicating how
women should be treated how are you
communicating how worthy you feel in
your essence versus your exterior and
you know i remember once my daughter at
a party in front of everyone i was
wearing a sleeveless dress
said oh mom let me see oh look at your
jiggly arm show people your jiggly like
helicopters right and i was like is this
kid the nut job i'm gonna punish her you
know what the hell is wrong with her but
of course i laughed at myself because i
had done enough work and i was like
outed this is what kids will do you know
they will point out all your flaws
because they don't see it as flaws
so i was like
here you go everybody and i made
everybody show their helicopter arms and
then i told my daughter
so sad you don't have your helicopter
arms yet because you can't fly yet and
look at me i've got plenty something
like that
but my instinct was to get upset my
instinct was to say i don't have
helicopter arms i have muscle look at my
muscle up here this is down here and
justify and defend
but you know or one day my daughter came
and said oh mommy
you know uh i don't want to get fat or
something or i don't want to something
about fat and i said i wanted to say to
her my reaction again was like are you
are you so silly you're so skinny i wish
i was skinny like you right that was my
instinct
but my because i knew this was coming
and you know when you're mother of a
daughter you have to be aware of these
issues i said to her i said if you're
fat you're fat if you're skinny you're
skinny today you're fat tomorrow you're
skinny
love your body no matter what maya
something like that you know
but my instinct again was to adulate
skinny them because culture adulates
skinny bodies so you have to be mindful
of these messages you know and let me
tell you even though i was mindful i
really messed up so it's not like some
perfection that i'm trying to convey
i'm just conveying an aspiration
and to be careful you know but we don't
have to be so perfect because no matter
what you do you're going to mess up
because it's a lifelong journey of so
many moments and no one is perfect you
know
the whole the whole the whole vibe of it
smells like codependency would that be
the right way to describe especially
maybe
i mean maybe and maybe it's just a
generational thing in patterning but it
seems worse than women
yeah it's worse than women because women
have been trained that their identity is
through the relationship
so
that's how why mothers enmesh with their
children more
and part of it is because we are
caregivers so we are lovely but our
loveliness becomes co-dependent in
measurement very quickly because we've
been trained from an early age
can you do can you actually just give a
good explanation of codependency because
i think these are the things too that
you know we hear it
and oh my god i i would have never said
i'm codependent i'm like i'm a strong
woman i
buy my own houses i do my own things i
make my own money i'm you know all kinds
of reasons why i don't feel like i'm not
codependent and then i realize i'm
totally codependent well i was much more
codependent and um so i think it's i
think it's a great great time to just
explain what that is um
because you know 50 of people probably
have it you know
yeah so codependency
is a specific condition
uh which is different from
interdependency
okay so codependency is a psychological
term that we throw around
which signifies that your identity is
really
dependent on the other person's moods
emotions and energy
so you can't hold on to your own
autonomous connection with yourself
and allow the other person to have their
own connection with yourself which is a
healthy interdependence but instead you
get deeply affected by the other
person's moods energies emotions and
thought processes so there's this
entangling
that we do and women tend to do it more
again because our nature is to care but
then culture has really effed us up in
telling us that oh caring is a good
person and a good person
really cares so therefore really caring
is managing the other person's moods and
emotions and that's where we go into the
other person's lane
and we mess it up
right so then we become co-dependent
what that means in layman's terms is we
lose ourselves in the relationship and i
tell people all the time you came last
you didn't lose yourself you came last
um and you can only blame the other
person so much because if you stay in a
toxic relationship then it's all on you
right
what one time it's on them two times
it's on them three months it's on them
six years it's on them but 25 years is
on you right
so that's where you have to take full
responsibility for your for our
co-creation
what are some ways that we can double
check if we're being codependent or not
i'm kind of curious about it from a
codependent side which you know i'm
really into attachment theory and
then maybe go in we'll go into the other
side of it where it's on the other end
of the spectrum because it ten
and i and you're the professional but
there's a lot of both of those right
there's a there's a lot of the
codependent anxious and then there's a
lot of the dismissive avoidant kind of
um disassociative um so like
two extremes right one is a boy
personality and one is insecure
anxious personality right right
either
right and they can both and they both
source from a very like how do you get
to each of those attachments and then if
we could go into each attachment and and
style of of relating and patterning and
how like just ways we can check in with
ourselves as to whether or not
we're in one of those
like where does it source from because
how do you become one or the other
okay so it comes from childhood right so
the anxious uh insecure type are is
temperamental
where they they learned to read other
people's moods because they were more
sensitive they were able to read so they
began to base their
psyche on the other person's energies
the ins the more disorganized avoidant
type personality uh is more
compartmentalized less enmeshed and they
just deny and
they're more masculine energy you know
so it could come from temperament it
could come from your own parenting and i
always tell people don't worry about
where it comes from
look at what it is
doesn't matter what is it now it doesn't
matter what you were yesterday it
doesn't matter but what are you
currently and the person can say
something like well i'm constantly upset
and affected
that's it so if you're constantly upset
and affected
you have to look at why and the person
will say because he because she because
they and it's the same cycle right so no
it isn't because of them it's because of
your co-creation so
become aware of how you're setting up
the dynamics for you to be upset
yeah they are doing them beautifully but
you're doing you beautifully so i often
tell very empathic women who are often
in relationships with more narcissistic
men
yeah they are doing their narcissism
down pat but they can only succeed
because you're doing your empathic
bleeding empath boundaryless you know
spineless human down pat right you're
not able to check in with yourself and
stand up for yourself so the narcissist
is more narcissistic so each creates the
monster in the other so we have to take
100 percent accountability for our own
misery until we get to a place of
hundred percent accountability not 50
50. you know i recently went through a
divorce and in my book a radical
awakening i talk about it that this
whole
paradigm of 50 50
is [ __ ] because it's 50 50 ego
when you take hundred percent
accountability i'm not saying
responsibility but accountability for
your happiness you end the ego games you
know so i did my divorce hundred 100 to
zero like
no 50 50. i didn't look for 50 50. i
looked for 100 and i could fly through
it so fast because i wasn't looking for
50. you see when you do 50 50 you're
waiting for your other half of the pie
you know you're waiting for okay i said
this now you say this but when you
choose to
be liberated you take 100
accountability yeah you give you give
things a chance to be 50 50 but
ultimately to change the pattern
you have to take hundred percent
accountability and this is where i get
the most resistance from people because
they're like no but he but she but he
but
and it isn't that people aren't wrong
it's not that people aren't wrong it's
just that if you want to participate in
that same pattern over and over again
keep playing but if you don't like it
then you have to realize that it's your
participation in it that keeps it alive
correct
and that acting in a certain way gets
that result and this is the kind of
person you're attracting like
i had patterning myself and i'm like it
took a couple and i was like oh
oh okay
and then it totally changes things yes
and and ultimately you know spiritual
teachers often talk about ultimately you
have to make a choice
and this is what we resist the most
because it's adulting to make a choice
is to be an adult
adulting is hard but nothing is hard you
want the choice made for you who
sometimes women come to me and
this is just to be taken lightly and
they're like i wish he would just die
and i tell them i i hear you you would
rather the person die you'd rather your
kids suffer
rather than you make a choice right
they're like yeah i don't want to make a
choice i want him to be dead right oh my
god because they
something in them has to die that's the
problem is they'd rather someone else
die than them because you you have to
die to parts of you to grow it's like
i i
before i want to close the loop
loops i want to close the loop on the
more avoidant style real quick and just
checking with that but then i want to
get into
um get into this transformation and you
know i always say growing pains there's
always pain and growing and like the
alchemy happens in the in the in the pit
of hell you know when you can't feel
like you're in misery but let's close
the loop on that on the avoidance side
and then pointed people are more
compartmentalized by temperament or
their own upbringing
and they tend to distract and numb and
uh go to another source
so the insecure anxious one begins to
attach parasitically to this to the
person and the avoidant
avoids the person and the relationship
and goes to a substance or to a thing
and to a new hobby and that's very
hurtful for the other person oh it's
the ultimate painful is the ultimate
pain for an anxious person yes and
that's the two who attract each other
and they keep the dance going
and so you know for the avoidant person
to wake up to their patterns is to
notice they'll be spending too much
money they'll be spending too much time
watching porn they'll be spending hours
on the couch in a video game their
avoidance will catch up with them
and hopefully then they can see that
they've been numbing
because they they've learned to run away
from their feelings and run away from
conflict so there's a lot of pain in
both sides and they have to do that in a
work and and so let's come to
transformation so how does
transformation really occur
is
you know you said the dying within the
self and encountering our own death
in terms of our psychological death of
pieces of ourselves that are negative
and dysfunctional is the hardest thing
right so i called my divorce
not a divorce to the person i called my
divorce a divorce from my own
authenticity i finally said no more
to my own game playing to my own role
playing to my own inauthentic self and
in my saying no the marriage couldn't
sustain itself
no problem
sometimes it can sustain
no it's it doesn't matter you have to be
willing to say no more to parts of your
own dysfunction
and when you reach that rock bottom
moment you will so i often tell people
who come to me for help
come back to me in a few years because
you aren't at rock bottom yet you're in
complain you just want to complain
and i tell them okay you understand you
just want to complain i'm taking money
just to listen to you complain and and
then they are jolted because they
realize they've just spent thousands of
dollars complaining i keep giving them
the carrot you know this is what you
have to do and what are the let me just
talk about the choice how do you begin
to make change ultimately it comes down
to growing up and making a choice and
they're only three choices
except where you are
and then zip it and
just do do what you're doing
the next thing is
change
and yes sure try to change the other
person take them for a a send them to
deepak chopra's courses take them to dr
shivali try your best to change them
at some point you realize if it's not
working oh maybe i have to change myself
and then the third choice so change is
change the other or change yourself and
then the third choice which is
only to be done with caution and not
through impulsivity is you leave
so accept it the way it is
meaning it is what it is it's it's 80 20
90 10 00 00. whatever you do except for
zero
whatever it is accept it and continue
like so many times when women will come
to me right and they'd be like i hate my
partner and i want to leave the marriage
so i'm like okay wow you want to make a
change let's do it and then when we
begin to talk about change they're like
oh but i love my swimming pool
but i don't know how i'll manage on that
allowance or what do i do here and i go
ah
you don't want to die change because
change means death
you want to complain
let's complain okay let's have a drink
together and complain right so i show
people that they want to stay stuck
actually so then i teach them just
accept and then they just love you for
that don't they they're just like thank
you dr shafali that's exactly what i
wanted to hear many times like how you
get them to do something right right but
many times the answer is to accept for
example
many women are stuck without money in a
relationship with 16 children and
they're like where where am i going to
go so i'm like you're right now you had
16 children accept it
except that he snores at night except
that he's a jerk what to do you got the
swimming pool you got the 16 children
you know what i'm saying however when it
comes to physical abuse i'm very
dogmatic i'm like no you need to take
care of yourself and leave now
but if it's you know otherwise life is
nuanced so you have to weigh and i can't
judge until you leave i can't judge and
tell you to stay you have to make that
equation for yourself right so i teach
people i empower people to make their
own equations but it always boils down
to
are you willing to really die because
that's what change means
or
let's look at other options such as
accept the situation how can we accept
it maybe you go to the basement he goes
to the roof how can we make this
palatable because you're not ready to
die yet and that's okay
but let's not pretend we're ready to die
and waste all this money in therapy you
know right and therapy is a great way to
you know therapists and i've worked with
many over time and um and even just
taking courses and doing things and the
prompts are really helpful and you know
the talking through things and you know
also verbally saying things is a whole
nother level to get things out of your
mouth that's been in your body in your
head
um
but i would say i mean but it's also
possible to do a lot of things on your
own and some people might not have the
means to do therapy and it could take
years you know for someone to really get
to the point that they're ready to open
up or hit a rock bottom of some sort so
i've had a lot of my actual biggest
breakthroughs have really
most of them have been on my own and um
through
being in a pattern or through
admitting certain things to myself and
what i don't want anymore and what i
deserve and things like that and and and
the process of of dying is it really is
hard and i'm wondering if you can kind
of
help
give a picture of what that looks like
and when someone can actually know if
they're not in therapy um
when they have gone through that because
i feel that people cut themselves pretty
short you know i feel like a lot of
times there's a there's discomfort but
then you know that's not really where
the alchemy is it's in a lot deeper
layers and levels and and and emotional
depth and and breaking down and so you
know how does that normally look for
people
so i think that you've been admirable in
your own endeavors to heal yourself but
i do encourage people to hire someone
because like you said when you hear
yourself talking loudly and you're
witness by a third party observer they
can point out things that sometimes we
cannot so how does one do it on one's
own is first understand that you may not
be able to do it on your own and it's
okay
but some of the things to do on your own
are to again
okay if i was to take hundred percent
accountability right now and somebody
was to tell me my pattern flaws what
would they be you have to do that
self-investigation
and break down the last fight you have i
always go to the last conflict and i
make them draw it out okay this was the
trigger this these were my thoughts and
feelings about the trigger where did it
come from what did it make me feel like
inside
what was my inner child feeling how did
my ego react and i teach people how to
do this loop building and breaking down
so there has to be some education you
know you can't just do it on your own
yeah yeah and then you begin to see your
pattern in it and then you say okay what
would it take for me to 100 break that
pattern
okay i say yes too many times okay where
can i begin to say no
where can i begin to take care of myself
better where can i stand up for myself
and speak the truth more and you have to
then so i did this in my divorce i told
myself i would not say
yes anymore till i was completely sure
it was a yes because my pattern was to
give off myself to make others happy and
then i was burning out and i was
resentful
so i just give myself a test okay check
in with yourself before you open your
mouth and if it's not genuine not
authentic and not coming from a full
place don't do it
don't say yes
so i began to not only not say yes i
began to not talk
because every time i began to check in
it was fake it was i needed this person
to like me or i wanted that person to
love me or and i was like wow i am
really in a persona of myself and i'm
not in the anchored place of
self-awareness and self-connection did
you feel lonely i was in a very active
uh fertile state of transformation so i
was determined to break my patterns so
it was not about loneliness it was about
really entering the beauty of my
aloneness and finding myself again and
and wanting to show my daughter that
women can be authentic and free and
showing my ex that i didn't want to be
the old me
and that it wasn't about him it was
about me so it was a very active fertile
exploration uh where you know and i tell
people that if you want to change
patterns
it is an introspective process it is a
journey inward so it looks less social
but you're getting to socialize with
yourself for the first time in your life
yeah and i've found too that a lot of
times not only will i mean relationships
fall away of all kinds not just the
romantic ones but sometimes friends and
other people and jobs and where you live
and you know that's kind of you know the
the new life just is going to cost you
your old life saying and and and it
sounds really scary to people but
it's it's the only way to true happiness
it is but we're scared of that tunnel
and we're scared of the new
and that's why until we hit rock bottom
in the old no one is changing you know
as a therapist for over 25 years i know
that people will not change till they
hit rock bottom so my goal is to show
people that it's not working we're so
afraid in this culture of fake happiness
to to admit that things are not working
but in the admittance that things are
not working beautiful evolutions are
possible but if we're attached to the
facade
then we are never going to allow a new
us to emerge and you know culture has
told us that longevity is the goal of
marriage and longevity is the goal of
relationships and so it shames us when
we want to when we want to move on it's
like i i i
think it's so sad to think that if
something ends it's a failure yes
it might mean growth too oh it it
nothing ends
that doesn't mean growth right
it absolutely means growth
and it takes courage for people to end
things you only end things because
you're brave enough to see that there's
something better for you and it's never
a wrong thing you know when people get
divorced and just speaking out of my
personal experience people you know came
to me and said oh i'm so sorry and i was
like who are you sorry for you know this
is people don't come to a divorce or a
change in a relationship out of a
weakness they come out of strength and
power
and um for sure i mean like but someone
can leave because of a pattern too what
if they what if someone's shifting
and they just don't like the the pattern
anymore and the person that's being left
doesn't even realize that's what's
happening there is sometimes
transformation that's happening that
disrupts the pattern as well that
doesn't always mean that the one leaving
is strong you know that's what i'm
saying like when stump sometimes when
you change things around you fall away
yes don't even quite become aware of it
because the stuff that happens
for me it's been like the stuff that
happens physically
emotionally
mentally tangibly aren't all on the same
at the same exact time
exactly so you're right but even though
it's not conscious the fact that it's a
change means growth is happening
so it may not be the growth at the level
of death that we talked about but it's
grown so meaning when you send your kid
as a parent to co university right by
doing that and taking them out of your
zip code and neighborhood change is
happening and growth is happening so
change is inevitable and you're right
that growth can be unconsciously
happening and we want it to be conscious
but it's change is always good like i've
never seen a change that's negative it's
only negative because we resist it right
that's so true
um i'm going to wrap up here by just
asking you i i i love to hear that when
you were young you love to ask all kinds
of questions ask big questions
introspective questions
um and i'm wondering
what now
at this point in your life are your
questions
um my questions are
um you know for me
professionally is how to make
consciousness more palatable for lay
people
so i i wrote all these very
philosophical parenting books that
helped people but i'm now giving people
more concrete tools i'm writing another
book on parenting that's more of a
method so professionally i'm always
looking for ways to help people to
suffer less
and i think personally
i'm looking for ways to make to grow and
make
parts of myself so much more whole that
i'm not
i'm not giving into culture
subscriptions out of fear so i'm always
trying to develop myself
so i'm a whole within so i don't give in
to these cultural pressures you know
culture has so much pressure on us
and i find myself sometimes giving into
it
and uh becoming inauthentic so
personally that's my you know how can i
become more authentic and how can i help
others suffer less
[Music]
big questions and big hopes for sure
there's a lot of people suffering from
so many of these things i mean social
media is wonderful and it's awful you
know that's it's the ultimate duality of
things everything is you know it's kind
of stemming from the same source but all
part of the same hole and the
expressions are all over the place and i
think we're in a really interesting time
in in in culture right now where things
are so
um getting pulled apart in different
directions
yes yes
yeah well thank you very much thank you
for the time and sharing your uh
experience and your knowledge and
ultimately just helping people become
more accountable if there was one thing
in my life people ask me like what are
you most proud of and i was like well i
think you're probably asking about like
my racing career or something like that
you know about my life what am i proud
of and and my answer is is always um
these days now uh
becoming fully accountable
um when my therapist said the words
no one holds the keys
i was like
oh [ __ ]
i was like that's a lot of
responsibility and i cried but it was
the best day
oh that's beautiful it's been a pleasure
danica thank you for having me thank you
dr chavali thanks everybody for
listening to the pretty intense podcast
today i hope you enjoyed it if you like
what you heard today and you want to
hear more please click on the subscribe
button